[Música]
sí
el chip
esa cosita tan maravillosa que traen
ahora los niños si se han dado cuenta es
que traen el chip y cogen cualquier
aparato y lo manejan divinamente
mientras nosotros los de generaciones
anteriores decimos qué maravilla eso de
tener el chip cierto y entonces además
hacen unas cosas simpáticas
i
su empate que riman
simpatiquísimas como estos stickers a mí
me fascinan estos stickers se han visto
que están de moda y cuando empecé me
empezaron a llegar de amigos míos y de
niños y con las fotos y yo no eso como
se hace no pero es que como yo no tengo
el chip uno cómoda sé eso pero
momento
y estos que los reconocen a todos
bill gates que no puede faltar en
ninguna presentación que hable de
tecnología steve jobs toro iwatani se
inventó el pacman esta es que los tres
nacieron en 1955 será que en 1955
repartieron unos chips
hicieron un piloto y dijeron vamos a
hacer un piloto para cuando vengan los
millennials y los centenial sera
pero estos que
paul allen
ese nació en 1943 nolan bushnell 1945 al
bayern 1922 entonces como la cosa del
chip estos también tenían un chip o eran
genios o cómo es la cosa pues les cuento
que en todas estas yo dije un momentico
yo creo que yo hay dios entonces no
importa ustedes no tienen paciencia
fuera del chip
esto estos stickers éxitos no los hizo
mía los hice yo que hasta hace seis
meses no tenía ni idea que era yo team y
blog change ni ninguna cosa de eso ni
las podía pronunciar ni un algoritmo
muestren un algoritmo me pongo visca y
genoma 24 es que yo también puedo si
este señor en 1922 no el otro en un
momento que es que esto de los chips
como que está mal repartido como en la
cosa pues no aprendí a hacer stickers
esto lo dice yo ahí estoy aprendiendo a
hacer stickers
entonces ahí fue cuando me dijeron a 24
am y mi chip yo también tengo un chip yo
puedo hacer speakers donde se embolató
el chip y bueno hagamos un recorrido a
lo largo de la vida como es la cosa pues
resulta que claro nace uno en una
familia en un entorno donde lo van
metiendo en sus limitaciones verdad
entonces tú que eres tan tímida y uno de
galicia es que yo soy muy tímida y al
otro le dicen tú que eres tan malito
para las matemáticas pero no importa ahí
está derecho literatura ciencia política
para cuando crezcas y al otro le dicen
bueno y entonces tú cómo eres el gordito
simpático entonces y uno va ejerciendo a
lo largo de la vida y así le van creando
todas las limitaciones a mi generación
le dijeron ustedes no tienen el chip de
nosotros crecimos sin chip y no la
creamos luego llega nuestro gobierno
nuestros legisladores y nos dicen sí
señores ustedes resulta que funcionan de
esta manera y de esta otra y vamos a
crear un chiste
educativo en donde así como en la vida
hay un ciclo que dice que uno nace crece
se reproduce se divorcia y muere
entonces también uno en la vida nace va
al jardín va al pre jardín a la primaria
al bachillerato a la universidad a la
maestría al doctorado y entonces así es
como nuestros legisladores nos cuadran
la vida y nuestro sistema educativo
obedece entonces aquí tenemos el sistema
educativo pero esto es un sistema
educativo viejo obsoleto antiguo del
siglo 19
porque aquí tenemos el del siglo 21 que
salvo por el color es más o menos lo
mismo cierto entonces la diferencia es
que no ya no le puede tirar la tiza al
profesor pero el resto no es mucho es
básicamente la misma cosa sistema
educativo que nos corrobora todas las
limitaciones que tenemos y nos dice sí
señor usted no sirve para ingeniero
usted no sirve para abogado y de todas
maneras la carrera de saber que todos
seamos doctores
y los profesores esta es una página esta
es la primera página del libro tiempos
difíciles de charles dickens que
escribió en 1854 y entonces en esa época
lo que decían que los profesores tenían
que enseñar a los niños eran datos y
realidades porque los muchachos no
necesitan otra cosa que realidades
pero eso era en esa época y ahora
también
bueno las empresas las empresas son las
otras que nos han robado nuestro chip
resulta que las empresas necesitan un
montón de gente pero sacan este tipo de
vacantes esta es una esta es una un
aviso de un portal de empleo real y
miren esto entonces se requiere para
importante empresa ejecutiva de ventas
tecnología de la información profesional
en administración de empresas de
ingeniería de sistemas con experiencia
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla y
que necesitan acá alguien que venda
tecnología que lo último que tiene que
hacer es ser ingeniero de sistemas sino
que tiene que tener otras habilidades de
empatía con la gente no es más no es
menos simplemente tiene que tener otras
competencias otras habilidades el sueldo
lo tache porque daba un poco de
vergüenza pero entonces esto es lo que
estamos pidiéndole al mercado cierto
los jóvenes los alumnos los estudiantes
que quieren a no es que yo tengo derecho
al libre desarrollo de mi personalidad
cierto y ejercer mi vocación de resultó
que a uno se le ocurrió que quería ser
azafata de cohete entonces el estado
tiene que montar les un asa para que la
niña tenga el libre desarrollo de su
personalidad señores jóvenes no van a
tirar tomates pero lo que les quiero
decir es que su vocación está perfecta
está espectacular está fantástica pero
su vocación tiene que servirle a la
sociedad y servirle a la sociedad de lo
que la sociedad esté necesitando no lo
que uno se le ocurre a cierto
y los adultos
aórticos digo adultos adulto test los
adultos los que no tenemos el chip y
entonces nos han dicho según el banco
mundial sólo el 21 por ciento de los
niños que en 2017 tenían ocho años se
desempeñarán en trabajos que hoy
conocemos y luego nos dicen según la
universidad de oxford el 47 por ciento
de los empleos que hoy conocemos están
en riesgo de desaparecer entonces los
que no tenemos el chip decimos dios mío
y entonces yo que voy a hacer mi empleo
a desaparecer y estamos todos en pánico
cierto ese es todo el contexto que nos
ha robado nuestro chip
todo esto que ha derivado en grandes
paradojas que hoy estamos viviendo
la primera en colombia por ejemplo hace
unos meses unas semanas salió el la
cifra de desempleo del mes de octubre de
1900 de 1900 de 2010 quien fue en
colombia 10.3 por ciento de desempleo
eso equivale más o menos haciendo los
cálculos de la población activa etcétera
etcétera 2.6 millones de personas en
desempleo en colombia y resulta que va a
uno a revisar las cifras de vacantes que
ha habido en los últimos cuatro años en
colombia' vacantes publicadas puestos de
trabajo que existen que hay tres
millones 823 mil ofertas de puestos de
trabajo en los últimos cuatro años
por otro lado el 45 de los directivos
afirma que no pueden encontrar el
talento que necesitan esto en un estudio
en 43 países incluido colombia no pueden
encontrar el talento que necesitan
en 2019 se calcula que solamente en
latinoamérica se necesitarían 450 mil
empleados de tiempo completo con
habilidades en tecnologías de la
información y las comunicaciones el 10
por ciento de es en colombia y las
empresas no los encuentran
el 85% de las empresas en américa
latina' consideran que las habilidades
no técnicas son tan importantes como las
técnicas y no encuentran esas
habilidades no técnicas según el informe
nacional de competitividad 2018 2019 no
existe personal técnico y tecnológico
suficiente en colombia para introducir
mejoras sustanciales en los mejores en
los sectores productivos
el 31 por ciento de los directivos
afirman que los candidatos no poseen las
habilidades técnicas y las competencias
sociales necesarias para desempeñar sus
funciones
qué está pasando entonces qué es todo
esto si todos los días nos dicen no hay
empleo no hay donde ocuparse etcétera
etcétera
bueno pues después de esta pequeña
saladita de orejas vamos a hacer lo que
obviamente toca hacer o no no puede
criticar sin proponer algo verdad
entonces que vamos a proponer familias
padres abuelos hijos todo el mundo
dejemos de encasillar nos a nosotros
mismos en lo que tenemos y lo que no
tenemos dejemos de encasillar a los
demás y decirles lo que no tienen y lo
que no tienen y entonces nosotros nos
ponemos en cuenta de que no teníamos el
chip y empezamos a ejercer de brutos
tecnológicos entonces la tía que no es
la llama uno por teléfono y cuelga con
el cachete y entonces empieza a escuchar
los números de uno tití y una hoja a la
tía la tía tan chistoso cita ella es que
no puede con la tecnología pues la tía
si puede con la tecnología no
encasillamos más a la gente y mucho y a
los niños es que ustedes tienen el chip
ustedes que es todo lo pueden bueno a
esos niños que tienen el chip no nos
encasillamos solamente en eso
enseñémosles que no basta con tener el
chip
que tienen que tener otras habilidades
para poder interactuar en sociedad
las instituciones educativas las
instituciones educativas están llamadas
a hacer esa balanza en reconocer lo que
las empresas necesitan y ayudarles a
identificar que ellos no necesitan unas
vacantes de unas cosas sofisticadísima
si doctorados y cartones la buena
noticia es que ya no tenemos que
inventarnos que tenemos cartones
los estudiantes del otro lado
reconociendo cuál es esa vocación de los
estudiantes pero enviándoles las señales
correctas no más carreras que en el
futuro no van a existir o van a tener
muy poca salida laboral démosle a los
estudiantes señores instituciones
educativas algo en lo que después se van
a poder desempeñar y el estado como base
de todo
los profesores señores profesores
maestros ustedes nunca van a desaparecer
nunca van a dejar de existir los
queremos los seguiremos queriendo pero
ustedes no son más los dueños del
conocimiento
ustedes son ahora coequiperos de sus
alumnos inspiradores de creatividad
inspiradores de co-creación de
curiosidad sean amigos y compañeros de
sus alumnos con su experiencia les
pueden enseñar mucho pero olvídense del
tema de ser de entregar datos de
información la información la tenemos
todos al alcance de la mano
las empresas las empresas identifiquen
habilidades y competencias habilidades y
competencias dentro de sus empleados y
ayude a sus empleados a moverse
horizontalmente no más empresas
jerárquicas donde las carreras llega un
momento en que tienen un techo y de ahí
no se pueden mover nos tenemos que mover
horizontalmente en las empresas y las
empresas deben propiciar que las
personas puedan capacitarse en
competencias que va demandando el mundo
las empresas tienen corazón y hoy en día
se están dando cuenta que si tienen
corazón y deben tenerlo y que necesitan
gente que lo tenga y que necesitan no
solo gente que sepa cosas sino unas
habilidades del ser porque entienden que
podemos saber todo lo que queramos pero
que si no sabemos comunicar si no
sabemos trabajar en equipo si no tenemos
habilidades de liderazgo
vamos a ser productivos y la empresa no
va a ser productiva
los gobiernos que los edificios
permanezcan así de bonitos por fuera
pero que por dentro se modernicen no
podemos seguir con largos procesos
legislativos y regulatorios que cuando
terminan cinco años después ya están
ocho años atrás de lo que se necesitaba
entonces agilidad en los gobiernos mucha
agilidad y conexión con el mundo no se
puede seguir legislando y regulando para
unas aspiraciones de quienes están allá
sentados sino para lo que el mundo está
necesitando y en eso tenemos como
decíamos abandonar la idea de que esto
es una carrera hacia arriba con
escalones a ver quién llega ya a doctor
señores jóvenes divinos ustedes que
pueden conectarse a hacer de todo ya
sabemos ahora que todos lo podemos hacer
pero no se olviden de las habilidades
sociales
señores adultos todos nosotros
acuérdense todos tenemos el chip todos
lo tenemos solamente son necesarios los
estímulos adecuados y que el entorno
pueda reconocer que los ciento jóvenes y
niños no solamente ustedes tienen el
chip lo tenemos todos y por eso todos
entramos ahora en el mundo que nos puede
acoger con nuestras propias habilidades
y que tiene que ver todo esto con lo que
justamente está pasando hoy en el mundo
todos estos movimientos sociales que no
hay que desdeñar en últimas se resumen
en una sola palabra
todas esas reivindicaciones se resumen
en una palabra que están pidiendo que
estamos pidiendo en el mundo equidad y
el sistema educativo es el mejor
distribuidor de oportunidades
de oportunidades la equidad se trata de
oportunidades iguales para todo el mundo
el sistema educativo es el que mejor las
puede distribuir y por lo tanto el un
buen sistema educativo es el mejor
promotor de equidad
yo no sé ustedes yo ya encontré mi chip
los invito a que todos ustedes
encuentren el suyo y hagamos parte de
esto que necesitamos
[Aplausos]